When knitting
traditional double bed jacquard.
The stitch pattern is worked on the main
bed and controlled by the automatic
patterning device,
punch card or electronics.
At the same time,
needles are in work on on the ribber
creating a backing and it covers
any floats from the stitch pattern.
Because the yarn colors are
changed every two rows.
Stripes are formed on the back of the
knitting. To alter the striped effect.
Settings are changed or a special carriage
is used that automatically selects
every other needle on the ribber.
The key is to have an even
number of needles in work.
The needles to slip are
alternated every other row.
On Brother machines,
you'll use the lili buttons.
The official name of these buttons
are the ribber Change knobs.
Silver Singer machines use
a separate bird's eye carriage.
Look closely and you can see
the slipped ribber needles.
Something to keep in mind is
that this technique not only changes
the appearance of the backing, but it
also distorts the front of the knitting.
Give it a try with your stitch
pattern to see the results.
Bird's eye backing will also
change the gauge of your knitting.
So if you're going to use birds eye,
be sure to swatch with that technique.